I remember the first time I ever saw a
picture of an ocean sunfish on the cover
of a Nat Geo magazine or something like
that I was probably eight years old and
I distinctly remember thinking why would
they put a picture of a half-eaten fish
on the cover of their magazine and I am
clearly not the only one who can't
comprehend what they're looking at I
don't know what this is
but Jay says it's a big sea turtle look
baby it's a baby wheel man holy
yeah witnessing a baby wheel right here
dude this disembodied swimming head
looks like the biggest joke played on
Earth it's often seen just sort of
flopping around at the surface and
getting stuck at the surface seems
inevitable for a fish that has no pelvic
fins and a backfin that never grows but
instead folds in on itself forever and
for a fish that looks basically immobile
it somehow gets absolutely enormous in
fact it's the heaviest bony fish in the
entire world for years people thought
that it somehow got energy from the sun
because how else could it get so
stupidly big even it seems surprised at
its own continuing existence its mouth
permanently gaping open literally unable
to close
when you first see this fish it's hard
not to wonder if this disc of a creature
is an evolutionary accident that maybe
it is somehow Breaking the Rules of
Nature rules which are supposed to
select for animals that actually
function survival of the fittest and all
of that how does such an awkward
slow-moving thing become so massive how
does it exist at all
these are valid questions but it turns
out this fish isn't as clueless as it
looks and it's stupid-looking deformed
body and all of its weird flopping
around on the surface behaviors do
actually serve a purpose this fish isn't
just eking out an existence in the vast
ocean but dominating it going places and
surviving in ways you would never expect
because sometimes being weird is the
best way to exist on this Earth
laughs
Sunfish belonged to the family mola day
and they are related to puffer fish
Triggerfish and box fish they're found
worldwide in the open ocean of tropical
and temperate Seas there are five
recognized species of sunfish ranging
from this odd little guy the dwarf mola
to this Behemoth the giant ocean sunfish
the largest one ever discovered was 6050
pounds or
2750 kilograms as heavy as a large SUV
and was 3.25 meters long and 3.6 meters
tall
and though they might look ancient
prehistoric or basically not of this
world or Dimension they're actually
evolutionary newcomers to our planet the
very first fish on earth emerged over
500 million years ago but the moladai
family emerged only 50 million years ago
in fact molas are thought to be one of
the most recent fish to appear in the
sea the first thing anyone notices about
amola is that it seems to be missing
half its body
its spine is indeed truncated and it
doesn't even have ribs its back fan
decides to never grow but rather it
folds in on itself indefinitely this
creates a lumpy round section at the
back of the body called a clavis it's
also missing its pelvic Fen and its
pectoral fins are small and rounded
the massive fins you do see are
oversized dorsal and anal fins but
what's perhaps the most surprising thing
about the mola is that it doesn't have
any axial muscles
in normal fish the axial muscles go down
the length of the body and are used to
flex the body laterally and the
undulation powers forward swimming so
without these seemingly essential
muscles how does the Sunfish even move
instead of axial muscles flexing the
body laterally the Sunfish has enlarged
muscles around its dorsal and anal fins
these massive fins flap simultaneously
propelling the Sunfish forward while its
body remains almost completely rigid the
fins direct water flow over them and
produce lift-based thrust forces
the Leading Edge of the fin is rounded
and the trailing Edge is tapered and
both fins on an individual are the same
size
these fins are literally just Wings
although vertical ones this is extremely
interesting from an evolutionary
standpoint these two fins originally
evolved in fish for a completely
different purpose and in almost all
other fish these fins are asymmetrical
the Sunfish co-opted these body parts to
create a different method of propulsion
in an incredible case of convergent
evolution with other underwater Flyers
animals with which it shares little
evolutionary history like manta rays
turtles or even penguins in fact the
acceleration signatures recorded from
ocean sunfish are remarkably similar to
free swimming penguins and although the
Sunfish fin structures are similar to
other ocean Flyers Sunfish are the only
aquatic vertebrate with its wings in a
vertical orientation like this in fact I
can't find any animal at all with wings
in this configuration
as it flaps its wings it oscillates its
tiny pectoral fins for balance and its
lumpy weird clavis acts as a simple
Rudder is this all very weird yes but
does it work also yes adult Sunfish
cruise at around 3 kilometers per hour
which isn't exactly fast but you know it
works and it works quite efficiently
because their fins are so big they don't
have to move fast to create a lot of
thrust on top of this their skin is not
like normal fish skin it doesn't have
scales and instead the fish is covered
by a thick hypodermis it's inflexible
and rubbery and also greasy and it's
made up of a meshwork of collagen and
elastin their body is so rigid that it
decreases drag and in fact this layer is
so stiff that it's considered to be an
exoskeleton even protecting them from
predators like sharks sea lions and
orcas although not entirely
the combination of high aspect ratio
fins and minimal body movements help the
Sunfish be efficient but it doesn't
really explain why the Sunfish moves so
slowly if anything this should help the
Sunfish cruise around quickly like tuna
who are cruising Specialists and also
have large fins and a somewhat rigid
body but there is one major difference
between these two fish besides the
obvious anatomical differences bluefin
tuna can maintain a core body
temperature of 24 to 35 degrees Celsius
even in water as cold as 6 degrees
Celsius the ocean sunfish cannot Elevate
its body temperature because it's
ectothermic endothermic tuna and sharks
can move much faster but at a cost it
takes a lot of energy to maintain a warm
body temperature in a cold ocean
so you might think that the Sunfish must
then hang around in Shallow warm Waters
to try to stay somewhat warm and they
usually do Sunfish are most often found
in water warmer than 12 degrees Celsius
because prolonged periods spent in water
at temperatures of 12 degrees Celsius or
lower can lead to disorientation and
even death but the Sunfish as we've
learned ain't no rule follower they
often go deep sometimes really deep all
the way down into the midnight zone over
a thousand meters down here the water is
Just 4 degrees Celsius what the heck are
these slow cold-blooded creatures doing
down there to find out researchers
invented the molacam they didn't call it
that but I'm calling it that this device
contained a camera a light an
accelerometer a satellite transmitter
and a thermometer that could read the
temperature of the water and the
temperature inside the fish with this
the scientists could see what the fish
was eating where it was going including
how fast and how deep
and they found that these fish were
going so deep in order to forage
specifically to forage gelatinous
Plankton mostly deep water siphonophores
during these Dives their body
temperature would drop from 20 to 12
degrees Celsius a dangerously cold
temperature why take such a risk what's
wrong with eating prey in shallow water
because the sunfish's prey isn't always
there while some species of jellyfish
May consistently hang out near the
surface much of what the Sunfish eats is
part of the greatest migration on Earth
every day billions and billions of tiny
animals move up and down the water
column all throughout the ocean this
movement is called the DL vertical
migration or DVM for short it's thought
that these animals swim up to food-rich
surface waters at night to feed when
light is scarce and they're harder for
predators to see and then return to the
depths before the sun rises
the Sunfish being one of those Predators
circumvents the zooplankton's clever
plan and simply Dives down to get them
using sunlight to help illuminate their
prey as much as possible and when they
dive so deep as to lose all sunlight
they likely spot the glow of their preys
bioluminescence
hunting at night when their prey is in
shallower water must not be as effective
for the Sunfish so they don't seem to do
it Sunfish always do their deep Dives
during the day and as you can see they
do a lot of them
with their awkward swimming and slow
speeds how do they manage so many heroic
Dives in a day for most bony fish this
amount of Rapid movement up and down the
water column would be a death sentence
due to the cold and due to their swim
bladder
swim bladders help fish stay neutrally
buoyant without having to expend energy
constantly swimming to stay in one
position in the water column but that
neutral buoyancy can only be achieved at
a small range of depths if a fish swims
below its buoyancy range its swim
bladder cannot compensate enough or
quickly enough and unless it swims
upwards extremely hard it will sink and
the more it sinks the harder this will
become until the negative buoyancy can
no longer be overcome on the other hand
if a fish swims above its upper buoyancy
level it becomes too buoyant its swim
bladder expands so much that the fish
might rise to the surface uncontrollably
if it does not compensate for this
increased buoyancy by vigorously
swimming downwards or aggressively
farting out the gas if this happens the
swim bladder can even burst swimming to
Great depths and back is simply out of
the question for almost all bony fish so
how does the Sunfish do it once again by
being weird they don't have a swim
bladder at all instead they're weird
dense bodies keep them neutrally buoyant
no matter what depth they're at this is
largely thanks to their hypodermis their
stiff gelatinous exoskeleton while a
sunfish's skeleton and muscles are
negatively buoyant they're hypodermis
tissue is positively buoyant and
incompressible the densities of these
tissues average out to be about the same
as the density of seawater with this
neutral buoyancy Sunfish use their
efficient lift-based swimming to travel
up and down the water column many times
a day and repeated surfacing after their
deep Dives is crucial because this is
how they warm themselves back up when
people see Sunfish from their boats
flopping around at the surface they
aren't stuck there or confused despite
how it looks this is in fact a type of
Behavioral thermoregulation basking in
the sun warms their body back up and
readies them for their next deep dive
this is also how they got the name
Sunfish their large surface area helps
them absorb more heat and helps them
float at the surface without using up
energy and the bigger the Sunfish the
more heat it can retain allowing it to
dive even deeper and for longer the
biggest sunfish are indeed the deepest
divers being enormous also comes with
some other serious benefits in the open
ocean because when you're a fish and
it's time to lay your eggs it's a
guarantee that many if not most of them
will be immediately gobbled up by your
hungry neighbors rather than be sad
about this the mola says I dare you to
eat all these eggs and squirts out more
eggs than any vertebrate in the world
made possible by having enormous bodies
with enormous ovaries to give some
perspective here the beluga sturgeon one
of the largest bony fishes lays up to 7
million eggs in a year bluefin tuna
another of the larger bony fish can lay
up to 30 million eggs but this doesn't
even come close to what the ocean
sunfish can lay a 1921 report stated a
single 1.5 meter female mola mola was
estimated to be carrying no fewer than
300 million OVA and more recently a 2.2
meter female was examined and found to
have between
875 million to 1 billion over in
different stages of reproduction inside
of its ovaries it's hard to even wrap
your head around how many eggs this is
mola released their eggs pelagically as
in they just squirt them out wherever
and then they are fertilized externally
but this has never been witnessed in the
wild for any of the five species of mola
no one knows how many of these eggs
survive and turn into full-blown molas
but with numbers this High the odds have
got to be pretty good
by necessity these eggs are very small
and thus mola mola growth is
mind-blowing for the quarter of a
centimeter larva to grow to a three
meters adult it has to increase its mass
by 60 million times one mola at the
Monterey Bay Aquarium gained nearly a
kilogram every day for 15 months and for
such a large bulbous creature their
larvae looks surprisingly much different
they're small and Incredibly spiky
likely to ward off would-be predators
as easy as it is to joke about this
weird and lumpy fish digging into its
adaptations reveals that being weird is
sometimes the best survival strategy it
unlocks new ecological niches with
better access to food and better chances
of reproducing and maybe that stupid
look on its face is also an evolutionary
adaptation to get everyone to
underestimate it maybe the mola mola is
the biggest hustler in the sea getting
Bamboozled by a big weird fish is pretty
harmless and kind of funny getting
Bamboozled by the media is way less
funny if only all we had to worry about
is the great debate about whether the
mola mola is cool or if it's dumb
unfortunately the world is more
complicated than that and we have to
worry about a lot of things student
loans the housing market fundamental
rights being Stripped Away we all want
to know what's going on but these days
The credibility of the news media has
started to break down we've all seen it
media Outlets only reporting on the news
they feel their base wants to hear or
sensationalizing things to the point of
absurdity to get the clicks with
hundreds of news sources out there it's
downright annoying trying to sift
through all the nonsense this is why a
good news aggregator app like ground
news is so helpful when Ground news said
they wanted to sponsor this video I was
so excited because it's an app that I
use every day ground news provides you
with a feat of headlines curated from
over 50 Outlets from all over the world
but with the content organized so you
can see through the spin and bias and
figure out what is really going on you
can quickly swipe through the different
headlines that different news outlets
are giving to the same story sometimes
the differences are subtle other times
not at all you can also see which news
outlets are choosing to ignore or under
report stories that are being widely
reported elsewhere you can even sort to
see the stories that are particularly
being spun one way or the other
for example this story about shipping
emissions and climate goals is being
widely reported from the left somewhat
from the center and almost not at all
from sources that lean right then when
you click on the story you can see a
graph of all the outlets reporting on it
and the bias distribution of those
Outlets it shows that it has only an 11
right bias and is thus flagged as a
blind spot story for people on the right
readers from any political leaning can
identify media bias and check Source
credibility there's even a web browser
extension that can show you the
breakdown of how news outlets from
across the political Spectrum are
reporting on the same story this all
helps you immediately notice certain
bias Trends which is helpful but also
fascinating seeing the different choice
of words and headlines from different
organizations while also seeing their
bias flagged is a super effective way to
see exactly how prominent and widespread
news bias really is it adds another
layer of interest to reading the daily
news as of now there is no feature to
show you bias from sources rating the
coolness of animals but you know Never
Say Never So if you're looking for a
better way to stay informed about
current events around the world check
out ground news by visiting ground.news
real science the link is in the
description you can try it free or
subscribe to get access to all the
features you see here and support
transparent Independent News ground news
is also offering all real science
viewers a special 30 discount on their
Vantage subscription the top level
subscription option this offer is only
available at ground.news real science or
by clicking the link in the video
description